tout ça j'ai pas que j'ai pas grand
chose je veux dire vraiment la vérité on
appelle d'entrée pas un truc mais on va
préparer un truc très vite fait un petit
truc sobre et assez d'accord mais sur
féret c'est l'anniversaire de crédit
c'est une petite souris dans un petit
gâteau c'est rien du tout mais pas que
on n'a pas eu le temps on va la préparer
juste le pro pas mal d'accord non c'est
l'anniversaire de kenny bon à l'arrivée
remarquée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la galerie pour la porter les gars c'est
bon c'est pour nous vous êtes un amour
mercier au crack habib attia cadeau pour
toi c'est vraiment merci à vous merci
j'adore ça tiens je vais les rangs des
saints et madame c'est mon anniversaire
est franchement voilà non j'ai fait mais
n'avons on a vraiment fait un petit truc
merci beaucoup et rien d'autre